sonia sotomayor the self-styled
wise latina woman on the supreme court
that's how she pitched herself to join
the court
she was hearing oral arguments over the
biden administration's vaccine mandate
and she
pulled a fact of of covet
hospitalizations
out of thin air
we have hospitals that are almost at
full capacity with people is severely
ill on ventilators we have over a
hundred thousand children which we've
never had before in in serious condition
and
many on ventilators
hundred thousand children in very
serious condition hospitalized many of
that hundred thousand on ventilators
that's just completely made up
there are right now and this is the most
wild outlandish generous liberal
estimate
there were fewer than 3 500 pediatric
hospitalizations from kovid
how many of those are really serious
totally unclear because a lot of people
are pretty trigger happy now if they get
the call if they'll run to the hospital
fewer than 3 500 hospitalizations
very different than 100 000
i'm beginning to conclude
that justice sotomayor may not be the
wisest latina woman out there
i'm beginning to but she went to very
fancy schools i think she went to yale
law school she's on the supreme court
and she
seems to believe this stuff
if a united states supreme court justice
believes
a completely outlandish delusion
about the scope of the coronavirus
epidemic
i suspect a lot of other people do too
i suspect
that the fantasy
is driving our discourse much more than
the facts
and i suspect that we are living our
lives and ordering our society and
making our laws and rules
much more based on fantasy
than on fact
i think if people knew the facts
about
the risk to children we would have
reopened the schools
much much sooner i think if people knew
the facts about the covid risk to
relatively young relatively healthy
people we would have gone back to work a
long long time ago
i just had coveted i just recovered
about a week ago it wasn't pleasant but
it's fine my whole family had it wasn't
pleasant it's fine people get sick
that's what happens
i think if if women knew the facts about
the now
accepted reality that the vaccines can
alter a woman's menstrual cycle at least
somewhat then maybe they would be more
reluctant to get it or they would they
would have some justification for
refusing to get it if people knew the
facts about the moral compromise
involved in creating the vaccines if
people knew the risk if people knew the
realities here and if people knew that
the
public health experts quote unquote and
the officials and their propagandists in
the media if they knew that they were
freaking lying to us
and just getting stuff wrong constantly
from the very beginning
they might look on this
biomedical terror regime with a little
more skepticism
but
the liberal establishment has done a
basically a pretty good job
at controlling
the narrative
with fact check after fact checked after
fact check that if you contradict it you
could be ostracized censored kicked out
of society and no one will hear from you
again i'm so glad you liked that clip
if you want to catch the whole show then
you got to subscribe ring the bell get
the notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe maybe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]